you
hello everyone we're glad you we're glad
you've joined us for this live webinar
samples management versus inventory
management what is the difference
presented by Kathy Shea and dr. Marcus
Albertini I'm Kristy drone elaborate can
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminars presented by
lab routes and sponsored by Brooks Life
Sciences for more information on our
sponsors please visit Brooks white
fine-tunes cone now let's get started
I would like to encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation simply type
them into the ask a question box and
click the send button we will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
now if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation click on the
support tab at the top right of the
presentation window or you can report
your problems by using the ask a
question box this presentation is
educational and it does offer continuing
education credits to obtain your credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
your presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit
lastly at the end of the presentation
you will receive a survey which we
kindly ask you to complete your answers
and suggestions will help improve our
webinar program and are greatly
appreciated
I would now like to present today's
speakers Kathy Shea bio bank business
lead Brooks Life Sciences and dr. Marcus
Marcus Albertini general manager and
director European region services flex
Life Sciences for a complete biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
Kathy and Marcus you may now begin your
presentations
Thank You Christy and thank you all for
attending today as Christy said we're
going to focus on inventory versus
sample management what's the difference
between them and why you really need
them both for your clinical samples
at Brookes we're really focused on the
sample everything we do all of our
products and services are centered
around the sample and that's because
samples are really the foundation for
how we build information and advance
scientific research to deliver new
diagnostics and therapeutics so that we
can all have healthier and brighter
tomorrow's if you look at the array of
products and services that we provide
you'll see that they focus everything
from the tubes that the samples are
preserved in automated or outsourced
storage solutions tools for handling
those samples today we're really going
to focus on information about the sample
they first have to ask yourself the
question why store
simples beyond the the clinical study
and that's really because there are key
resource for preclinical research and
clinical development well organized
collections help us get a better
understanding of the etiology of disease
and the biological pathways that
contribute to that disease as well as
allow us to have new therapeutic
concepts new discoveries whether it be
target discovery or biomarker discovery
associated with a particular disease and
in the clinical stage we use this
information to help us stratify patients
look at particular subgroups within a
population develop new companion
diagnostics and even identify rare
events and so a good comprehensive well
organized sample collection can really
make your research and development
processes much faster save save time and
enable collaborations between different
institutions
so one of us asked this question why is
it so difficult to keep track of samples
and one of the foundational things that
goes into answering this is the wide
array of different simple types that
there are so what you see here is a list
of very high level sample types that
people have an association with a
clinical trial and within any one of
these you can have lots of variation so
for human simples for example you can
blood blood derivatives many other
matrices that you need to store
information on and the key information
associated with each of these samples
can vary based on the sample type as
well as the disease that's being studied
and you'll find there's a lot of
inherent variability within our
overarching biobank collections that
results in a lot of complexity
first and foremost most of our bio bank
collections have samples from many
different clinical trials and those are
acquired we also have material that's
acquired from various different
suppliers and through lots of different
collaborations also within each one of
those collections there can be many
different stakeholders and those
different stakeholders often have
different purposes they have different
objectives whether it be for the primary
trial or additional research and also
have different areas of the research and
development pipeline that they're
actually focused on whether it's in the
particular diseases etiology or the mode
of action or doing broad research on the
sample sets adding to the complexity is
the number of locations both internal
and external work samples can be stored
and the data associated with those
samples are also stored in many
different locations and many different
systems and so if you ask yourself Gina
do you always know who stores what
samples at what place for which purpose
and how are they in the related data
stored for your organization most of our
clients would say the answer to this is
is no because there are so many
different players involved in storing
samples and associated data
so when you're looking for a solution
for how best to manage this really the
first question you have to ask yourself
is am I looking for inventory management
or sample management
we say inventory management really
referring to the lot where why and how
much of a pimple do I have that the what
is specifically what is is that a source
sample type is it again is it whole
blood is it a derivative of that whole
blood what was the the source of it
where is the material stored as I
mentioned previously you can have lots
of different parties involved in a trial
no samples from a single participant can
be spread across multiple locations why
you have it is is really about the
intended purpose and then of course you
need to know how much of it you have for
that for your future use
but if we turn to sample management
sample management includes all of those
things that we just talked about for
inventory management but then brings
along with it all of the metadata
associated with a sample so whether that
is you know patient clinical data a
demographic data family history consent
information the primary study protocol
under which it was collected all of the
methods used during the collection and
preservation process and then I think
most importantly actually the analytical
data that was generated from that simple
because as we do additional analyses and
we start building data stats associated
with each sample we're really unlocking
the intelligence and getting maximum
scientific value out of that because we
can leverage the information that has
been previously learned for our future
analyses
so what we're looking at now our compost
or common sample and data flows for a
clinical trial so typically starts out
with a collection kit going to a
clinical site the clinical site
collecting the sample but also
collecting the data associated with that
participant who provided that sample and
as the samples and the data begin to
move through their workflows there are
many different parties involved in these
workflows on the data side there are CRO
s involved you can have ecrf fenders
that are also aggregating data from the
clinical sites you also could have lots
of laboratories typically you'll have
one central laboratory associated with a
single trial but you can have multiple
specialty laboratories and so within a
given trial you can wind up with
multiple different data systems that are
storing information all related back to
the sample and one of the things that we
always encourage is primitive
reconciliation between those data
sources so that while the trial is
ongoing you're resolving any of any
discrepancies between the different data
sources but ultimately bringing that
information together in a centralized
system or centralized view into systems
is what's really needed for researchers
to be able to query that data and find
samples that meet their their intended
research purposes
but this gets more complex when you
start looking at viable Bank collections
because each trial has its own
individual workflow and its own
individual set of stakeholders and
players that participate in that trial
and when we start adding multiple trials
together we can see that we wind up with
the picture gets a lot more complex
because now instead of having you know
four to six vendors associated with a
single trial you're talking dozens of
vendors could be involved when we start
going across trials and data often winds
up residing with particular study groups
and can be very fragmented and hard to
hard to get at and so being able to set
up ways in which you can bring that data
together from double trials multiple
systems and multiple types of data to
create that holistic view is really the
holy grail in terms of is in terms of
sample management
so bringing this to the simple
management lifecycle it all really
begins with the the plan for your study
and as you go through the process of
collecting processing storing analyzing
your materials each step of these
prophecies adds additional data and
additional information that is important
to the downstream analysis associated
with that simple whether it be for the
primary study or whether it be for
future research purposes so planning out
each step of this process is very
critical
and on the left here you see the the
normal processes that that a simple will
go through from the time a donor is
enrolled and that initial collection
happens all the way down through
analysis when you're planning out your
process really the the first questions
to ask are what's going to be collected
who's going to be doing the tasks
associated with that collection and when
is it planned to occur
the data elements that are going to be
collected in association with those
processes are also critical you need
consistency and standardization so that
information across different locations
can be shared so creating a data plan
that outlines the type of data how that
data is going to be q seed and how
frequently you're going to reconcile the
data between different systems becomes
instrumental in having and having good
clean data on the back end
also when you optimize logistics you can
also really have a big impact on the
over cost associated with the sample
portion of your trial so looking at the
frequency of sample movements that are
going to be required and organizing the
samples in such a way that really allows
you to facilitate access to those
samples is is key
and so it starts with defining the the
process and who all of those players are
going to be you know a lot of people
will let the the sample purpose in
multiple buckets and what what do what
do I plan on using for my active trial
what simples need to be safe for
regulatory purposes and then what will
my future use samples be but in reality
they all really follow the same path
whether they're making you know going to
a central lab initially or specialty lab
or coming right from the clinic or
patient to biorepository
our overall processes are the same it's
about transporting the the samples
registering them into the centralized
system processing and storing and then
analyzing either now or in the future
but really to accelerate clinical
research you need to make sure that
those samples are in a secure
environment that they're audited and and
handled in a consistent manner to really
protect that sample integrity and and
very importantly allow for fast
retesting or additional testing when
needed either during the active trial
itself or later for that future research
and in order to achieve this you really
have to have good transparency into your
sample collections and when you
centralize this and you focus on your
overall data plan you can really
increase your data quality your sample
quality and the uniformity of
information that you have
and finally reducing cost again by
pre-planning things to optimize your
logistics pass look at doing batch
processing with possible and
consolidating across vendors can make a
significant difference in your overall
study budgets
and when considering cost one of the one
of the things that we always like to
advice is make sure that you do the math
associated with it so typically people
know what material wants to be collected
and it let's visit it needs to be
collected then when you start planning
your aliquot n plans you really have to
say what is the total number that I'm
going to and anticipate if you're only
collecting one sample per patient then
that math is is pretty simple but when
you start collecting samples across
different matrices and you're looking to
have multiple aliquot those numbers can
can really ride increase and drive up
the cost of your study so and for
example I had one particular trial where
it was meant to be a rather modest
collection and essentially by the time
that we started looking at all of the
single-use files that were initially
requested those numbers can go up
tenfold from what's actually going to be
needed for a study
and then looking at your storage format
is is also important in the upper right
hand corner you see a picture of a
standard cryo vial and even in this
picture be a very good eye sight you
could see that what happens with most
standard cryo vials as they only a
portion of them gets filled during
standard cryo vials while traditionally
that works incredibly well from a
storage density standpoint they actually
do take up a lot more space and so
planning your storage in a way that you
can maximize the the footprint will help
save storage costs for you in the long
run
and with that I'm going to turn it over
to Marcus okay thank you so much Kathy
yes till I call this slide preparation
support sample management management
supports preparation and that's heading
in the direction that we are looking for
samples that are really best fit for our
purposes and especially if you wanna use
the samples for broader research later
on why not store them for a long time
it's it's really important to focus on
certain aspects that may help us to
generate the quality to have the purpose
of use and the scope of use in place we
meet later on may be many years later on
and to stay complained a compliant with
our sample and sample usage so the
purpose and scope of use that is very
important because we need to take this
forward into the IC efforting
and we have to align this with
regulatory or IRB requirements meaning
what we stayed in the ICF is written
there and we have to comply to this
we'll have to use the sample and of
course also the data i put data there
attack times here on the slide because
without the data the sample is not that
useful as with them we kind of have to
stuck to this and of course we may also
have to go back to the ICF to dig out
relevant information what can we do with
December then of course we should have a
clear picture about the sample types and
taking procedures now how we did it what
kind of sample we have and maybe also
what kind of sample we would like to
have in our collection like kind of
streamlining this sample logistics that
was already addressed also with
considering cost it's very important to
route the sample have an idea
do we wanna route it am suited to the
center
laughs or maybe directly rooted into the
bio bank do we want to move it into the
bio bank after reconciliation or can we
considered it before and then tackle if
something comes up during reconciliation
later on and then have a clearer picture
how we want to store on the geographical
side and what are the storage conditions
are all assembled on the collection okay
then at a later point of course and we
also need to access our samples and
having a good sample inventory in place
that our researchers and every other
stakeholder can really see what we have
there to come up with ideas to do their
research planning is another important
building block in the concept of being
really prepared for setting up a good
sample collection a long-term sample
collection in the end all this together
enables us a sample analysis every wish
as we wish or proceed they are easy to
collect the samples having the right
samples in place and of course allowed
to use the samples for the purposes we
would like to use them
I'm looking a little bit deeper into the
purpose and the scope of use I try to
summarize this year in in this overview
scheme starting with mandatory and
ending here with voluntary mandatory
means how can we include our purposes
and the scope of you into the informed
consent for the patient
what will the other committees accept
what is regulatory possible and also
data protection has to be considered
because also the essays we should inform
the patient or the donor of the sample
what we plan to do with it and of course
also with the data and then if you look
here if you just go or the indication
yeah the classical or traditional
clinical trial yeah looks into one
indication a disease and we try to show
that our compound we bring forward in
that trial is safe and it is
sufficiently efficient but this is very
often not broad enough here basically
it's the mode of action we are looking
after and it's a glass of compound so
taking forward to frontrunner compound
and the front-runner compound shows some
problems some issues regarding safety or
efficacy we have to go to the backup
compound meaning our ICF may state
something that does not allow us to use
the data for research on the backup
compound compound going for the class of
compounds or the mode of action has us
to overcome this limitation we may even
jump into another therapeutic area if
the mode of action and maybe even the
compound that was originally developed
for an oncology therapy is also very
helpful like in respiratory diseases so
there are some examples out in the world
yeah where that happened and we would
like of course to use our samples and
data also in that case that we
originally collected in trial Oncology
and then of course you may look into
biomarkers biomarker research and that
could be
as additional objective so then you see
the lines in the middle to the left or
to the right basically defining a scope
where you may have a good chance to take
your ideas in your purpose and your
scope of use forward in the main consent
as a mandatory requirement for
participating in the study the topics
below the line it becomes more difficult
and it may you may need more efforts to
discuss with your ethic responsible
persons if that should be done if that
will be allowed by the ethics committees
that means for example going for the
syrup Lloyd Beauty area we are still
closer to the indication than asking for
use of the sample in all biomedical
research and then of course to going to
the right yeah would be future research
there you also have the time span with a
exact storage of 15 years or 30 years
what do I need for a storage and
depending on that it may be mandatory or
more voluntary that means the patient or
the donor of the sample becomes the
opportunity to freely decide I want to
provide my sample for future research I
do not want to do that so we made some
experience that depending on the
indication if it's voluntary you will
receive like in diabetes about 60 to 70
percent of the patients that will agree
to provide the samples up to 90 percent
if you go for oncology like the more
sick the people field the more open they
are for providing sample and data for
future research
so taking this into account how could a
bio bank or a repository look if you be
to the left it says clinical trial
samples that's basically the light blue
block there this is the sample
collection where we would have 100% of
our study participants members of all of
these and then you combine study one two
three four five any studies and you can
always go back for your original
purposes to this collection and you will
in any case F 100 percent of study
patients to answer your question because
that year the clinical development
biobank and for the definition mode of
action giving you freedom to operate but
limit you if you want to go around
research related to to the mode of
action or the class of compounds on top
of steps you could for example ask them
to also voluntary agreed to further
research to broader research they are
basically you could then use a subset of
your sample six to ninety percent also
for open research questions that may
come up over time then defining a
defined as research biobank basically
the dark blue box and the two grey boxes
that would be a sample collection
enriched also for samples acquired from
vendors the app occurs in a clinical
trial the more invasive you go to
difficult the more difficult it is to
get the samples you may have a need
facing need to have also additional
samples in your collection and then of
course collaborations there are many
good well undertaken bio banks out there
in the world and clinical centers may
also help to further enrich your bio
bank in the end
you
so how can we best reach that without
being too complicated having to do too
exhausting reviews of our ICF and an end
kind of to keep control over all of our
samples and studies and they come from
different places are differently stored
at different places maybe as Cathy lined
out before so my slogan would be keep it
simple work with standards and stick to
them you will have a good understanding
about what you have in your bio bank and
what you can do with it while staying
compliant and if I talk about standards
it's pretty simple standards what I
propose meaning I have before I start I
have an idea what are the minimum
studies in my organization in which I
will perform bio banking or collect
samples for biobank like for a pharma
company it could be all private or
studies all studies that help to bring
compound to the market or what is my
maximum long-term storage timeline for
example 15 years or maybe you say 30
years and take the 15 years as a big
fall fallback position if the
regulatories or the ir bees do not agree
to the 13 years then of course have a
good understanding what sample types and
mattresses I would like to have per
therapeutic area that helps you in the
end if you wanna use assembles across
trials what do I need how should my
already urine be collected do I need a
sediment if I collect urine of the
urania that may depend from therapeutic
area to therapeutic area and have a good
understanding what I may need in the
future helps you to have it in place
yeah to collect right things for the
future
then of course who I want to have
leftovers with leftovers I mean not a
backup sample that didn't have an
additional resource cycle by the sample
that comes back like from a analytical
laboratory like an oncology whether or
not shouldn't take that much blood from
the patient it may be a consideration
verse in under indication we may say no
we don't want to have that in our
collection because we are not sure about
the quality and then of course as Kathy
already touched before aliquot Eng yeah
when and where do I want to do the
recording at a study site by the temple
temple speaking at the central lab or
before it goes in the bio bank or maybe
even when I take it out of the biobank
yeah it's the important thing is how
many three saw cycles do I have in the
end then of course sample taking
procedures and storage locations and the
minimum scope of use as explained before
do I need a hundred percent of the
patients or can I pay a price for doing
broader research by not having 100
percent of the patient one last thing I
say F and CTP wording there should be
good template this should be pretty
stable
the wording shouldn't be changed within
a trial or maybe even a above trials so
you can be pretty sure it's the right
thing but it's the right message in the
ICS and basically I only need a yes or
now the ICS there I now what's India if
you can establish that in your
organization and ICF and CTP we found
very often that the ICF wording is in
conflict with DDP wording and vice versa
and that may generate a problem so we
recommend have keep an eye on this
then linking clinical and biomarker data
we believe this is essential to link
them to the sample to have the full data
the the full data repository available
for good research to really have to view
what they do I have available and to
have the opportunity to get this data
for my analysis also that needs to be
established by the ICS and then of
course and that sometimes generated
additional issues I do research with my
sample and that research very often
doesn't go back in the original like in
the clinical trial database or wherever
your data are stored but they are more
or less free-floating
and with the researchers that perform
the research and that may give you
relevant additional information about
your sample you want to also include
this into your data collection that is
tacked to the sample and all this given
data privacy and protection especially
now with the GDP are in place in Europe
is a very important aspect of all on our
future analyzers to keep the privacy of
the patient or the donors and we should
do that is providing their sample and
the data for research to support us and
that should be well and knowledged
so what could be safeguards to protect
the identity and the privacy of our
sample doughnuts doughnuts of course we
only see or most of us only see the
coded temple or the coded data comes
with subside Oh name double blinded
single blinded depending on how we want
to do it what we want to do with the
sample we may decide to anonymize it at
a later point all this defines the
measures we have to take to keep the
privacy safe of the of the sample donor
important is that samples and also the
corresponding data are stored in a
secured and access controlled
environment that means we need to know
whether gas access and we need to know
what the people that have accessed with
the data and of course we should have a
process in place where we have a
committee where we ensure that all the
right steps are taken that control and
allow in the end sample access and use
according to the ICS then standard
operation procedures at least in pharma
they are stunned that we need them we
work under GCP and also the samples are
collected under JCP and they staying
under GCP also if you use them later on
for research purposes of course we do
not validate or do not need to validate
our equipment and our methods for
research purposes but we still need to
have the audit trail on this end
okay and in the end of course we should
also destroy or use the symbols
according to the informed consent
meaning we need to have two time stamp
on it and we need to know when they have
to be destroyed
I just made a little box down there to
the right
addressing to GDP are summarizing few of
the key elements like the data donor has
to write to be forgotten you can request
that is the data can be dated that's not
that relevant in the context of GCP
because there we have a law that makes
us keep the data a long time but if we
go into research it's more critical I
will allow to keep the data they made
the data deletion may compromise our
research results M or do we have to
delete the data questions that are
really discussed between the other
protection laws between scientists they
are and they're still not all very clear
then there's the right to know who uses
the data and the data donor can request
information about what we do with our
business data and most importantly
before analyzing any data before
processing them we need the legal basis
to do so otherwise we wouldn't be
allowed the legal basis could for
example be di CF
you
so what are the challenges of content
management of course we have a diverse
if you go for global trial or study
ethical environment where the
regulations continually evolving new
ones evolving the anticipation of
regulations change and they may differ
between country to country because of
cultural heredity and that makes it of
course pretty difficult to work on a
global basis with one SEF and to fulfill
all the requirements from the ethical
perspective
so going a little bit more in detail
it's of course we need to ensure the
identifiability of the sample at the
same time we need to ensure that the
donor is not identified we need a clear
view on the breast of the informed
consent the authorizations we have in
place and the requirements we have to
put in place to keep control of this
then withdrawal of consent we need to
take care of death it is and the longer
the sample is the more difficult this is
like receiving a withdrawal after 15
years in the organization so that hope
doesn't happen that often but that may
provide us with considerable challenges
depending how we are organized privacy
restrictions I already touched genetic
research information we need to keep
track of this are allowed to do all the
pranaam sequencing to rida wanna do
whole genome sequencing we ask the
patient for that did you agree on who
genome sequencing then storage and
retention of samples how long when do we
have to discard or what can be used and
transfer of samples of course are
allowed to him or export the samples and
the same is true for the data yeah are
we allowed to export it to the US for
example how what does data protection
regulations in Europe say about that
intellectual property ownership and
commercial lose is another aspect and of
course return of research results what
do we have to return to the patient to
December donor having this all set I
highlighted legacy studies here because
legacy studies they require most of the
time menu review and they are the
studies that really hurt us because they
we have to do lots of foot work to
really have to right picture what we are
allowed to do with the sample
so hopefully a consenting and better
data integration will help here in the
in the future taking took all this
together basically these are the factors
that define the space of our assemblies
utage
you
excess model ethically we need to now we
need to undertake to sample
pre-analytical variables and you need to
have a clear picture develop clear
reports for reviewing root meaning we
group all the samples studies there
according to the usage what is allowed
yes set a threshold for level of review
required like a legacy sample we need
much more review efforts then we would
need for our studies where we are our
head our standards in place and where we
could can be sure that the standards
were followed globally from country to
country that the M ICF didn't change
from the wording and from the meaning
so thereby we can group into low-impact
samples or studies meaning only minimal
review is required or call it a risk
based approach we can be pretty sure
that we stay compliant when we use the
sample for certain purpose
and the other one of course is
high-impact where we need a stringent
review where we go have to go into
detail where we have to really carefully
look into our documentation in our data
to get a full picture and to be really
on the safe side when we take the sample
out of the repository
so overall there are thousands laws
regulations and guidelines on human
subjects which are subject research in
place and of course we are talking about
more than 100 under 20 countries where
these regulations apply and the
regulations are said there is a
geographical variance there's
differences it's not in each and every
country the same and therefore it's
really important to keep oversight in
principle it can be said that eight
categories that are covered by such
regulations and guidelines in general
those applicable to most or all types of
human subjects research so that's really
to our heart then of course drugs and
devices and the development and approval
clinic clinical trial registries
research injury privacy data protection
also very important for us in biological
materials genetic genetic research
embryos stem cells and cloning so if you
would like to get a better overview or
you look for a special country issue you
may use this web link it's a very nice
tool and its really worth within taking
it if you didn't do already so lots of
information and and very well done
brought together
having collected samples having them in
a systematic way in a bio repository in
a bio bank of course the collection will
grow it will grow over time more and
more and more and we should also have a
strategy in place how we assess this
collection what do we really need where
do we have quite an overflow of samples
can we use December yeah to keep it
really to the purpose your collection
yeah also your research strategy may
change and for that reason admit code
makes totally same sense to assess the
collection it may save you money in in
the end and it helps to keep you to keep
overview
starting with the clinical data of
course the first question is what data
what clinical data do I have available
then if the data I have available of
importance for other studies that may be
conducted to the scientific impact they
may bring can I do cross analysis
business data will they help me in rice
research project and then of course the
data quality is the data trust what
trustworthy do I have control parameters
in please a place that can give me this
information depending on what your
outcome on this question is you say no
and then you may discard the samples
because the data bases is not good and
the information the readout of the
sample will give you may only be limited
or worthless the second question if you
have this answered with the yes will be
the consent the ICF agamya
will it allow me a broader you or use
according to what I plan to do and do
the samples and process purposes meet
the definition of your subject research
as I say have been reviewed for use
broader than the original study plan use
the ICF contain a provision for you to
be on to original purpose and collection
and then of course time genetic use
these areas specific consent coding
require this is very important and that
may also result in a yes or a now so we
have all this in place
the sample seems to be quite usable we
should keep it yeah that means
after a final suitability suitability
assessment yeah what is the potential
use of the sample starter is it fit for
the purpose we may have to take the
decision yes it is and then we keep it
but going through this scheme asking
this question this helps you to really
really really build and under tain or
maintained by receipt or e that suits
your purposes that has the quality you
need and that has also the amounts you
will you foresee and you can afford for
your future activity
so summarizing this forum structure
functions for sustaining your bio Bank
basically this means define and annotate
the collection the primary study what am
i defined and Salieri's my aliquot what
follows from the mother sample what are
the future research purposes and what
I'm allowed to do for future research
then it would be good to set the
threshold
do I have to expand my collection do I
have renewable resources how to bring
this rate in the three new world
resources when needed and of course it
could always be considered to also
acquire limited resources that I cannot
get for example through my clinical
trials and I think that's also very
often something happening in
organization that acquired samples are
not in the same system then the
collected samples are meaning they are
not seen and very often researchers do
not really know what kind of required
systems I have in my organization and
also bringing this into one sample
inventory may considerably help to
enforce and enable research and then of
course culling of abundant resources may
also be considered
overall this means and to develop an
impact based review process of the
collection we are doing the collection
assessment and of course taking mid also
into consideration individual research
questions I may need this collection for
so what in summary are the critical
sectors for successful inventory and
sample management
starting on the left side at the bottom
temple and data standards its temple and
data standards do I have the right
symbols are they collected the right way
do they have the quality I want to have
is everything in place but it may also
be the standards how I collect the
temples and data and how I'm prepared to
collect them in a way that I can use
them later on then single view of
inventory a very important aspect if you
wanna plan you research your experiments
you need to know what you have to work
on meaning having a view and having a
view on the relevant data that gives you
the information but maybe the samples
that are valuable for your planned
experiments give you the full
information if you have sufficient
numbers of samples if you can do the
experiment and how strong your power
will be for that experiment then of
course cause consolidate sample assets
bring all the assets you have together
make them visible in one inventory tool
have two full overview what you have
then linking clinical and biomega data
and sample information together also is
the basis for your research for the
quality of your research and then
repository assessment as said before
helps you to keep focused help you helps
you to be the best to undertake the best
for your purposes and the collection
taken together that will help you to
have a good a better management may be
in place for your bio bank so
comprehensive data visibility that a
utility utilization of samples pass the
sample access better data quality and
uniformity regulatory compliance
reduction of course of course that may
be what you gain from a
but from working from a pragmatic sample
management approach so coming to an end
we all know someone that is impacted by
disease so the samples are so great
they're precious to us because they are
the key to unlocking scientific
discoveries the proper collection and
preservation of our samples and they
associated the data will allow us to
advance science to create healthier and
brighter tomorrow for all of us having a
good sample collection in place making
this available for scientific research
support development of new therapies
compounds and in the end will be the
good part on the way or the basis really
to make a change regarding diseases
having to set
we are open for your questions
Thank You capya Marcus for your
presentations on how we can know the
difference of sample management versus
inventory management's so let's get
started with our Q&A now just a quick
reminder to our audience on how to
submit questions if you haven't already
done so just click on the ask a question
box located on the far left of your
screen and click the send button and as
a reminder any questions we are unable
to get to today Kathy and Marcus will be
answering them via email so don't worry
if we don't get to your question right
away okay our first question now Marcus
this may be for you I believe it is is
standardization of sample collections
achievable
yes it's achievable so I was running bio
banking operations globally for quite a
while
and the important thing is that you have
two stakeholders in your organization in
the boat meaning you have to do training
you have to convince them to support
this and if you are organization
supports is and it is watertight it held
holds true it works and that helps a lot
it facilitates the use of dissembled
assemble collection basically every step
on the project lot and in the end you
may really be able to reduce the
question can I use the sample for that
purpose - yes or now - I have I see as
in place or do I not have it in place
thank you for that now cabbie let's come
over to you what policies do companies
have in place for return of research
results and or incidental findings
think that you know we actually find
that this is a question that lots of
different companies struggle with
you know research results are just that
they're they're still researched the
biomarkers that are being studied have
not yet been validated biomarkers for
for that particular disease and we find
that most companies findings that they
have that are on biomarkers that are
still in the research phase they don't
release to to the study participants
because it's not known whether or not
that's it that's a true result at the
point where we're still in the research
mode now when there's an incidental
finding associated with a validated
biomarker that's quite different and
that typically does get returned to the
clinical site for reporting to the
patient
Thank You Kathy now Marcus let's come
back to you how frequently do I RVs
agree or not agree with having future
research sample collections mandatory
for participation in clinical trials
so my experiences maybe others made
other experience having future research
that goes beyond the indication of the
disease of the original clinical trial
having this mandatory in the read by the
effect boards M is very very difficult
yeah meaning the moment you cannot
inform the patient and I think that's
the critical point about what will be
done with your sample makes the ethic
experts say it should be voluntary you
cannot tell the person in the what the
sample will be used for you should give
him the opportunity to say yes or no I
think it's it's fair
it doesn't make our life easier we have
to to live with the situation and have
to find good ways that we that we can do
good research the research is also for
the patient and the donor in the end
yeah and at the same time acknowledge
the rights and the needs of of the
sample donors donors
Thank You Marcus now I'm going to pose
this next question to both of you and so
for you to weigh in my question is
related to the challenges of consent
management now when a patient is no
longer alive or the sample is destroyed
or are they still accessible for what
they consented are there any specific
rules or regulations in place
why don't I take the first stab at this
so typically samples are retained after
a patient devised if they have consented
for their simples to be used for
research purposes then the samples and
the data that goes along with them
typically are preserved one of the
interesting things is in the United
States once a person is deceased
they never they don't no longer fall
their samples and data no longer fall
under the human research protection laws
because they're not considered a human
research any more because they are no
longer alive but I'll tell you that most
groups that I work with really all
groups that I work with actually treat
samples and data from deceased donors in
the same manner that they do from live
donors meaning that they respect the
individual permissions and restrictions
of use of that sample even after a
person dies Marcus do you have anything
to add to that now I agree I've the same
view and I think the only thing that may
to be considered is if we go for genetic
analysis here then of course there's
also information about a family India
and I think that that may be a point of
discussion where we do not have the full
picture right now
Thank You Kathy and Marcus on that no we
have time for one last question
Kathy won't look close with you does
Brooks offer sample management system
that can track all the variables
discussed
we do we actually have simple managed
inventory management systems and simple
management systems available our
inventory management system is freezer
pro and our simple management solution
is bio bank Pro and actually on on the
screen right now you see a link to our
website you follow that link you can get
more information on those systems
Thank You Cassie and Marcus for your
time today and for your excellent
presentation I would also like to thank
slab reset our sponsor Brookes Life
Sciences for underwriting today's
educational web seminar now before we go
I would like to thank all of you for
joining us and
as a reminder those questions we did not
have time for today and those submitted
during the on demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration now a survey will pop up on
your screen and your participation is
greatly appreciated this webcast can be
viewed on-demand and laboratory alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event you will now
be redirected to the registration page
for our upcoming webinar on August 14th
at 9:00 a.m. Pacific time continuous
improvement in sample management
presented by Bill Leavitt J Patel and
Zach Kobler we hope to see you there bye
bye